c'est l'un des plus grands marchés d'île
de france le marché du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie compte 250 commerçants
ici on trouve de tout des fruits des
légumes du poisson de la viande des
vêtements et des accessoires un marché
très vivants avec une énorme ambiance et
on va tout de suite rencontré les
commerces
pascale mussard fait partie des
commerçants les plus anciens il vient
ici sur le marché du val fourré depuis
30 ans est un producteur de légumes et
il produit ses légumes à fontenay saint
pierre et il est avec nous bonjour
pascal bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi vous avez
décidé au tout début depuis 30 ans
maintenant que de vous installer ici sur
le marché du val fourré parce que c'est
il ya il ya un gros volume de ventre et
puis
c'est une époque on est beaucoup de
marchandises et puis du coup on a trouvé
sa place ici vous devez avoir beaucoup
d'histoires sur ce marché on a rencontré
beaucoup de monde et puis
neuf et connaissances et puis y'a plus
maintenant on a des japonais koné
bientôt deux générations donc oui
pourquoi il est particulier ce marché
pour sa convivialité bon déjà il ya un
gros volume de ventes et en plus c'est
un lieu de rencontre alors est-ce que
vous pouvez justement nous dire en quoi
consiste votre activité qu'est ce que
vous faites et qu'est ce qu'on peut
trouver chez vous bah tout ce qui assure
tape déjà fatou légumes racines pommes
de terre carottes
les oignons c'est pas des racines mais
de rutabaga n'avait topinambours tous
les légumes et puis bah toutefois la
sonde et on en hiver donc c'est chou
vous cardon et toute la gamme des
potirons potter note
bleu de hongrie musqués et puis alors
voilà à peu près fait le tour et il se
dit sur le marché que vous êtes un peu
le thermomètre de ce marché dès le début
de la journée si vous avez du monde sait
que la journée va être exceptionnel
c'est vrai
est impossible mais presque
et ça je peux être noté si on vous l'a
dit c'est que c'est quelque chose mais
là bon je peux me vanter au plus
[Musique]
on trouve pas mieux ailleurs
parce que tout est moins cher et je
mélangeais par rapport à l'ambiance
c'est plus familial et les royals il est
magnifique et les gens sont splendides
[Musique]
et après avoir fait ses courses sur le
marché de mantes-la-jolie on peut aussi
se restaurer par exemple avec ses
spécialités algéroise et pour en parler
nous sommes avec yasmine santos bonjour
bonjour alors est-ce que vous pouvez
vous nous expliquer ce qu'est en train
de faire s'il à votre maman est là en
train de faire d'une semaine c'est fait
avec de la semoule et de la farine ça
vous préparer ça à la maison et puis
après vous venez les faire on fait tout
sur place de tout tout tout sur place
l'a pas tout est fait sur place et puis
il ya d'autres eux aussi petite
spécialité il ya des beignets de poisson
il ya de la galette kabyle qui est fait
elle même de semoule après y'a des
sardines né à des gâteaux ya un peu tout
bon et pas maintenant on va passer à la
dégustation qu'est-ce qu'on peut
déguster ici alors là à faire goûter
pour faire un moment inoubliable c'est
la galette et la sortie on y va à
sardines c'est ça c'est en fait la
sardine des noix de l'été on enlève les
arrête
les ouvre et on met de la farce à
l'intérieur on fait une sur l'autre on
fait cuire à lui
merci yasmine parce que le thé à la
menthe c'est une tradition à agir et
bien voilà c'est ici que s'achève notre
excursion sur le marché du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie un marché qui se tient
le mardi et le vendredi de 12h30 à 18h30
et le dimanche de 10h à 18h et moi c'est
parti je vais commencer à manger parce
que ça a l'air très appétissants
[Musique]